und so viel ist man kann so viele tolle
sachen machen und dann schießt 10.000
fotos und neben 1 hey leute was geht ab
monats willkommen bei einem neuen video
hier mal wieder auf einem kanal also ja
auf jeden fall habe ich ja vor zirka
zwei wochen mal so ein video rausgehauen
dinge die mädchen an jungs nicht
verstehen ja genauso um was und archive
heute gedacht kommen was ganz einfach
mal anders rum drehst das mal und zwar
geht es heute darum dinge die jungs ein
mädchen nicht verstehen und ja ich
wollte ganz viel spaß
logischerweise fangen wir an mit punkt
nummer eins und zwar kann ich es einfach
mal überhaupt nicht verstehen warum
mädchen jetzt ausgerechnet so eine
schöne handschrift haben und jungs
einfach mal überhaupt nicht selbst wenn
ich mir jetzt vorher nehme ja kommen
diese hausaufgaben machst du jetzt mal
richtig schön und schreibst langsam und
damit deine deine hausaufgaben dafür
auch schön aussieht dann dann sieht das
auch schöner aus als wird jetzt ganz
normal schreiben aber es kommt immer
noch lange nicht an hand drücken aber
oder an die handschrift von mädchen
heran
und da frage ich mich einmal woran liegt
das bitte ohne scheiß jetzt ich hab noch
nie irgendwo eine handschrift von dem
mädchen gesehen oder gefunden
die schlimmer ist als meine und ja keine
ahnung kann er nicht verstehen woran das
liegt kann das mal irgendwas sagen
vielleicht seine kommentare was ich auch
einfach mal überhaupt nicht verstehen
kann ist warum sich mädchen war egal was
ist ja da ist man ein bisschen dreck für
auf dem boden oder so die stellen sich
bei jeder scheiße stellt sich ein
mädchen an
außer es geht um fotos machen wenn man
nämlich dann fotos macht dann ist
scheißegal ob das fällt jetzt ob es
gerade geregnet hat oder so hauptsache
das foto ist später schön was man halt
auf facebook instagram oder so stellt
und damit auch direkt die überleitung
zum dritten oder nächsten punkt und zwar
mädchen schießt ja immer 10.000 bilder
aber nehmen dann im endeffekt aber nur
eins ich meine ihr habt so viel ist man
kann so viele tolle sachen machen und
dann schieße dann 10.000 fotos und nimmt
uns ernst und ihr müsst auch schon hat
wenn ihr jeden tag 10.000 fotos auf
eurem pc
eine gewisse menge an speicher ist
wodurch ein pc ein langsamer werden kann
ja wohl nicht ich habe mir im letzten
video gesagt von technik kann mir nur
jungs eine ahnung wer das dann unser
vorteil mal so dann kommen ja jetzt auch
schon zum letzten punkt und zwar können
die jungs ist einfach mal überhaupt
nicht verstehen warum mädchen jetzt
ausgerechnet so lange brauchen um sich
fertig zu machen wenn man dann weil sich
so selber als beispiel im jahr fünf
minuten fertig ein mädchen rauch
ungelogen 20 mal so lange auf jeden fall
gibt es eine menge vorteile über die
euch ja vielleicht noch mal gedanken
machen können ob das jetzt wirklich so
wichtig ist sich zwei stunden fertig zu
machen oder aber das ganz vielleicht
auch auf eine stunde reduzieren kann
schreibt eure meinung dazu auch einfach
mal wenn die kommentare wird mich auch
ehrlich gesagt mal ziemlich
interessieren was ihr darüber denken
egal ob jungs oder mädchen lasst eurer
fantasie von meinungen freien lauf oder
so und damit war es jetzt auch leider
schon wieder mit diesem video ich hoffe
natürlich es hat euch wie mal gefallen
und ihr geplanter beiden daumen nach
oben
ja wenn es nicht ganz so gefallen und
auch einfach daumen nach oben und noch
mal ein ganz herzliches dankeschön für
schon über drei komponenten ich glaube
es ist sogar schon fast 3200 oder so
geht auf jeden fall mega ab zurzeit
dafür ganz herzliches dankeschön check
die beschreibung für instagram und
carolin nicht vergessen auf jeden fall
gc unten links jetzt weiter mit meinem
letzten video ja das war's bei mädchen
und jungen rechts mit dem anlagen dinge
von also dinge die mädchen an jungs
nicht verstehen schön schönes wochenende
noch heute rein und ich weiß gar nicht
warum ich immer so machen